[Music]  no man can fully grasp how far and how  fast we have come there is no strife no  prejudice no national conflict in outer  space as yet it has it's a hostile  towards all its conquest deserves the  best of all mankind and its opportunity  for peaceful cooperation may never come  again  the missions primary goal has been  achieved looking at a large single sound  biological I'd hate it on the car but I  think it's time we're looking at the  first proof of life beyond Earth you  finally a daddy it's gonna be a big  custody battle over this one beautiful  [Music]  we set sail  we ask God blessing  dangerous and greatest adventure on  which man has ever embarked this nation  will continue to be a pioneer in the new  frontier of space borrow for me I'm  really a message